foreign
go through the um
High evacuation announcement the
emergency evacuation and announcement
um
great there are no planned fire drills
this evening so if the alarm activates
please leave the building in an orderly
fashion by your nearest fire fire exit
the two fire exits through the partition
doors are currently not in use due to
ongoing Works therefore the fire exits
are through the main doors of the hall
or the storeroom adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance so the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silent please toilets and hand
washing facilities are available in the
foyer area
members of the public
and welcome
while you are of course entitled to film
or take photographs during this meeting
can I ask please can I please emphasize
to you that this should be done without
disruption to the meeting can only be
done from a designated area in the
public seating can I please therefore
ask you to raise your hand clearly were
we that's uh routine stuff but yes thank
you
um so
there we are
thank you very much indeed
all right
the um further points remember there's
need to use microphones all this stuff
you really know during the meeting when
I invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking uh these all switched on
and ready for you to speak and will be
unmuted by officers for you
please make sure the microphone is
directly in front of your mouth before
speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations we'll also
ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
right
at that point
members and members of the public
visiting councilors can I
welcome you to this meeting of the
executive this evening
before we move into the agenda proper
um
I would like to make members aware and
visiting members the sad passing of
Michelle power who was an officer in
this Council until a year or two ago she
worked in Democratic services
and can I also draw your attention to
the absolutely shocking and Dreadful
scenes that we're seeing on our
television screens of the earthquake in
turkey and Syria we are fortunate in
this country not to have those sorts of
occasions but I'm going to ask for us to
have a minutes silence if we may just to
reflect on the life of Michelle power an
officer in this Authority and also spare
some time to give thoughts to the
Dreadful issues going on in turkey and
Syria and you know our thoughts are with
them at this very very difficult time
members one minute silence please
[Music]
thank you very much members
yeah
right
um we moved to item one apologies for
absence well everyone is here so there
are none uh item two non-members
attending
um councilor Michael Hoy from Rochford
District Council and councilor Jill
white from Brady Town Council uh I think
I've told everyone else yeah
um right minutes of the meeting held on
the 19th of January the minutes have
been circulated and
um members are you content for me to
sign those minutes as an accurate record
of that meeting
agreed thank you
right item four to receive Declarations
of Interest
any Declarations of Interest none
Right Moving On questions on notice from
councilors
um I've not been informed of any
questions on notice from Members so we
move on to item six which is matters
referred to the executive reports from
other committees and I have to say that
I'm a little surprised there's a blank
chair there where I was expecting to see
councilor Stuart Wilson this evening
reporting back from overview on scrutiny
were we expecting him to be attending
tonight's meeting
okay all right well we'll push on um
it's always nice to see councilor Wilson
but uh as he's obviously not been able
to make it uh tonight
um so um
if we turn to
item six 6.1
um report of the overview and scrutiny
committee
um relating to the sustainability
strategy
um
counselor Mrs Danielle Belton along with
no doubt Marcus hotton if you would like
to do a bit of a double act on that and
introduce the points on that
um so members you've got a chance to see
this sustainability strategy
um and review that in depth and
obviously it went to ons where a number
of recommendations have come forward
I'll go through those recommendations
now
um recommendation one is at the
sustainability strategy as appended be
approved and adopted recommendation two
that the climate and sustainability
offer supposed to be made permanent
three that are climate and
sustainability Committee of 11 11
members be established on a pro-rata
basis and four that the climate and
sustainability committee meets on a
quarterly basis now I just want to
comment on item three
um on the evening there was some talk
about the makeup of the committee and
the importance of it being represented
by all groups on the council and the
number 11 was floated on the evening but
subsequently Emily has confirmed that
nine would achieve the same outcome so
if we were to go down the route of 11
members it would be made up of six
conservatives one green and independent
one liberal one Rochford District
resident and one independent and a group
of nine it would be five conservative
and one from each of the groups with the
11 one of the groups the Green
Independence liberal Democrats and Roger
District residents one of them could
take an extra seat just to remind
members that as this is is an executive
committee it doesn't have to be set in a
pro rata basis it has to be set as we we
agree but I think it is really important
that everybody has the opportunity to be
um represented on the committee given
the weight of the the climate um
situation
so I would like to make a Amendment or a
proposal for an amendment to item three
that a climate and sustainability of
nine members be established to achieve a
political representative committee
thank you do you have a second of all
that Amendment
councilor FD
thank you
thank you and if I may make one more
point on that if for any reason any of
the groups do not wish to be represented
I would like to put forward that one of
the other groups could take that
position
um this this committee is about
transparency working together and
essentially putting some good ideas on
paper to bring forward to this exec to
improve the council
thank you very much indeed um
Mrs Belton councilor Mrs Belton uh right
okay well we have four recommendations
before us from the overview and scrutiny
committee uh one has been amended uh so
uh with that amended item on three
um if I read them out one that the
sustainability strategy has appended be
approved and adopted is that agreed
read that the climate and sustainability
of supposed to be made permanent agreed
that's a climate and sustainability
Committee of nine members be established
on a pro-rata basis is that agreed
that a that the climate and
sustainability committee meets on a
quarterly basis is that a
um
political representative basis
okay
um I think your pardon yes the subtlety
of that is passed me by so right just
moving back to item three that a climate
and sustainability Committee of nine up
members be established to achieve a
politically representative committee
agreed
thank you for pointing that out
right with regard to
item 6.2
I wish to make a statement but before I
do Council award is there anything that
you wish to say in respect of item 6.2
thank you very much indeed chairman
um yeah I am actually quite disappointed
uh that councilor Wilson isn't here I I
think he's an excellent chairman of
overview and scrutiny and I've been very
pleased to have seen him and introducing
these items
I am very very disappointed that this
item was actually deferred because I
think it's a very important one and it
runs in conjunction with the next item
we're actually going to be discussing
because they are
very much interlinked and extreme
extremely interlinked but it's not here
it's going back to om s
to look at again and I look forward to
them bringing their recommendations and
their ideas forward to the next meeting
of the executive so I will hand back to
you
um as far as any comments that you have
I've expressed my own disappointment
that we're not dealing with it tonight
thank you
okay
um and as chairman of this committee I'm
sure you will appreciate members of the
executive committee uh including myself
are extremely disappointed by the
overview and scrutiny committee's
decision to defer the Mill Hall item
last Wednesday evening
Not only was this highly embarrassing
for the council as the guests invited in
to constructively participate in the
meeting were turned away without having
a say but also the portfolio holder and
officers had put in a significant amount
of time and effort into preparing for
the meeting which essentially went to
waste
a further point that I would make is
that one of the individuals who attended
had given priority to attending overview
on scrutiny and had not accompanied his
wife that afternoon to attend his
mother-in-law's funeral the next day and
imagine the heartache that must have
given him to a given priority to a
meeting that evening where his input
wasn't required and I was desperately
apologetic to him in particular
the decision to defer also put at
Jeopardy the executive's ability to take
important decisions around the operation
of the Mill Hall which will ultimately
ensure its longer-term viability to
which his conservative Administration is
fully committed to
the executive recognizes how important
it is for good governance that the
overview and scrutiny committee and the
executive have a positive working
relationship
the deferral decision could have
resulted in the executive having to
proceed with the decision on the 7th of
February without having the overview and
scrutiny Committees of valuable input
however we have reviewed the
implications of not considering the item
tonight and I can confirm that we are
able to accommodate the report returning
to overview and scrutiny committee on
the 23rd of February ahead of the next
executive meeting on the 7th of March
this is a most serious matter and whilst
we have been able to adjust our
decision-making timetable on this
occasion that may not always be the case
and I must stress that we cannot find
ourselves in the situation again where
the executive cannot conduct its
business because the overview and
scrutiny committee has not fulfilled its
proper role I will be writing to the
chair of the committee councilor Stuart
Wilson to this effect
thank you members
any other comments on that point
and it's agreed that we differ
thank you
right moving to item 6.3
report of the overview and scrutiny
committee uh relating uh on the 1st of
February 2023
um relates to the community investment
plan Council award and Phoebe I think
it's double active in the two of you
thank you very much indeed chairman well
this is a very very important document
that's coming forward the community
investment plan
basically this is to invest throughout
the district
totally and absolutely and the the
recommendations that we have
looked to address
are on page 6.3.2
we do have other recommendations that
have come from overview and scrutiny but
I would like to really go through
The View that we are taking as far as
this is concerned
basically this community investment plan
and its objectives that are set out
or following
a very very fundamental route
that the allocation
of funding for this community investment
plan will be prioritized based on the
three key objectives that originate from
the partnership with Sanctuary Housing
Association and the deed of variants
these three objectives will assist
Rochford District Council and
Century Housing Association in their
complementary roles as important a place
like Shapers and makers within the
district so I would like to highlight
the items on 6.3.2 item
1.2 part 3 that delegated authority be
given to the interim director of
resources and the director of assets and
investment in consultation with the
leader and the portfolio holder for
strategic planning and assets and the
portfolio holder for finance economy and
climate councilor Daniel Belton sitting
next to me to draw down funds from the
community investment plan
ring fenced reserved to support the
following there are three items
up to a total of 255
000 pounds to support expected works of
000 at the Mill arts and event center
and up to 45
000 for replacing the furniture at the
Mill arts and Event Center to enhance
the offering for events there plus up to
000 to support the external resource to
deliver the future plans and business
case for the mill arts and event center
point three
up to a total of three hundred and fifty
thousand pounds to support the
objectives of regeneration outlined
within the CIP proposals this money will
support the technical work to bring
forward regeneration sites in the
district to Reba stage two supporting
the Regeneration strategy approved by
this executive on the 9th of November
up to a total of 75 000 pounds to
deliver a comprehensive community and
stakeholder engagement process to
support and align with the technical
delivery of the Regeneration sites now
chairman I would like to go back to the
recommendations
subject to overview and scrutiny
committee which one can see on 6.3.1 and
there are four recommendations
they are the community engagement
exercise should include meaningful
market research to achieve the best
outcome for the Mill Hall
number two pay 7.4 paragraph four that
the Regeneration strategy is aligned
with the new local plan
three that we look to work in
partnership with charitable
organizations and others that are able
to access grants and four that the
delegated spending Authority is limited
to one hundred thousand pounds and any
decisions in excess of this value are
referred to the full executive for
decision
chairman those are the various
recommendations and proposals within
this community investment plan
I I hand over to you unless there any
further questions or anything that any
other members or officers wish to add
thank you very much Jim thank you
councilor Ward for that very
comprehensive overview of the report uh
members are there any questions
right okay
um have you got a second of your
recommendations that came forward from
counselor Mrs Danielle Belton thank you
um the recommendations have been read
out to you
um but just for the tape
we'll go through the recommendations
once again and they are shown on page
6.3.1 Act 2 and the first recommendation
number one the community engagement
exercise should include a meaningful
market research to achieve the best
outcome for the Mill Hall is that agreed
members
agreed
page 7.4 paragraph 4 that the
Regeneration strategy is aligned with
the new local plan is that agreed
number three that we look to work in
partnership with charitable
organizations and others that are able
to access grants is that agreed
and that the delegated spending
Authority is limited to 100 000 pounds
and any decisions in excess of this
value are referred to the full executive
for a decision is that agreed
thank you very much
I guess I was uh
doing the shortcut but of course there's
recommendations within the report that
you read out to council award so we
turned to 1.2 on page 6.3.2 so not only
have we got the overview and scrutiny
recommendations but the proposed
recommendations within the report that
the community investment plan objectives
set out within Section 3 of this report
be approved
and can I have a show of hands for those
in favor
thank you that's unanimous following
approval of the objectives that the
proposal set down within section 4 be
approved that's item two again can I
have a show of hands for those in
agreement
unanimous
and three that delegated authority be
given to the interim director of
resources and the director of assets and
investment in consultation with the
leader and the portfolio holder for
strategic planning and assets and the
portfolio holder for finance economy and
climate to draw down funds from the CIP
ring fence Reserve to support the
following
up to a total of
000 pounds to support expected works of
185 000 pounds at the Miller arts and
event center and up to forty five
thousand pounds for replacing the
furniture at the Mill arts and events
center to enhance the offering
for events there plus up to 25 000
pounds to support the external resource
to deliver the future plans and business
case for the Miller arts and Event
Center
and up to a total of 350 000 pounds to
support the objectives of regeneration
outlined within the community investment
plan proposals this money will support
the technical work to bring forward
regeneration sites in the district to
Reba stage two supporting the
Regeneration strategy approved by the
executive on the 9th of November
and up to a total of 75 000 pounds to
deliver a comprehensive community and
stakeholder engagement process to
support and align with the technical
delivery of the Regeneration sites can I
have a vote in favor by the wise of that
those in favor
thank you that's unanimous as well and
obviously those later recommendations
are restricted with the authorities
shown in the recommendation from ons so
that item is concluded members
and we move on to our regular item our
monthly item at every executive which
I'm pleased to see coming forward each
month on the cost of living update which
is item seven I think councilor Williams
and Tracy Lily are going to guide us
through this one I think we might even
have a slideshow hope we
if I may thank you chairman he had the
decision being recommended this evening
is at the end day of the cost of living
response and work or the cost of living
work working group be noted I'm going to
ask
um director basically to take this hold
for us thank you
thank you councilor Williams yeah just
to kind of bring you up to speed and
apologies I couldn't be here at last
executive
um it wouldn't have been safe for anyone
but I'm really really proud actually of
the work that we've done in the district
around the cost of living and as members
will know I've been very clear it's not
what we will do for our residents the
staff and our businesses actually us as
an enabler to enable the Fantastic
Community groups and partners that we
have and I don't want to steal Kelly
stand because I've invited Kelly today
to present the dashboard to you which
we've promised but one thing I do want
to say is that work that we've done and
we're busy doing it has been recognized
by the local government Association so
they've included it in a case study of
the excellent collaboration with
partners and the work that we're doing
on the cost of living and I was also
invited to the cost of living conference
to talk about the excellent work that
we're doing in this District so I just
want members to be assured that you know
whilst we're not out there doing
everything we're enabling the right
organizations the right groups that we
have the right
Charities and everything they're so
fantastic and the support that we've
received is is incredible and everyone's
really really committed but as I said we
were going to develop a dashboard which
we've done and Kelly is going to present
to you I would just add the caveat that
I've put in the report that it's in its
infancy and we have to rely on partners
that some of them are already stretched
delivering the services that we want
them to deliver so I didn't want this to
be onerous on them in terms of collating
the data so the available data to us is
not available until the 21st of every
month so the data that you'll see in a
moment is for December but the plan is
that this will then inform us moving
forward so that when we come to
September of this year and we need to
start putting things in place then we'll
have all of that data available to us
but that dialogue is happening on a
daily basis in some respects our website
is constantly updated but I won't steal
Kelly's Thunder I'll hand over to her if
you
thank you Tracy sorry it's gonna open up
a load of different
um updates now
sorry about this I'll find the right one
in but there you go
um so I want to present to you today the
cost of living data dashboard
um as Tracy's told you this is a
partnership approach I know it's it's
worked it's been embedded through the
covid work and through the development
of the community Hub our partners are
small but powerful
um and they they really have stepped up
to the mark yet again and I have to say
yet again because it feels like we're
asking them to do something every time
we're in crisis at the moment they are
under a huge amount of pressure so I've
split up the dashboard into what I think
makes sense I hope it makes sense
because data is not easy to gather
especially when you're Gathering it from
different sources so the top area is
support from Council Services given in
December so we talk about the cost of
living related calls received by
customer services and the contact center
the number of people that have applied
for discretionary discretionary housing
payment so those that find themselves
suddenly in difficulty
the number of those apply for council
tax reduction scheme so this is
generally because their circumstances
have changed
or someone in their household their
circumstances have changed those the
number of at risk of homelessness which
we know is always slightly elevated at
this time of year and homeless
applications and I think that this gives
a Bare Bones Narrative of how at the
council we deal with cost of living on
an everyday basis
um customer services stepped up to
actually give us that data to collect
that extra data for us so every time we
ask a question or ask something from
someone we're asking them to do a little
bit more so it's not easy the dashboard
is not perfect but it will get better in
terms of support from Partners when I
talk about Partners we're talking about
citizens advice we're talking about ravs
we're talking about the Hub at the mega
Center and we also get some soft outcome
information from some of our charitable
Partners like trust links and I'm hoping
to bring that data on board at a later
basis but it's going to be more
qualitative so you'll see that in the
identified needs and trains
um so the number of seeking number of
people seeking support for warm hubs
we've done a fantastic job we put some
money towards that five thousand pound
came from the executive it was well
spent it went in the first two weeks I
have to tell you and Victoria had
trouble actually getting it out quick
enough
um but as expected I can tell you the
uptake is actually really low
um because we have such a resilient
District we found this too in covid that
people helped themselves they helped
their neighbors they will help
themselves in their community and we've
got a really strong faith Network and
what's interesting is that quite a lot
of the faith organizations didn't take
that money because what they said is
that's what they're already doing so you
won't get their numbers
um
that's just a fact we knew that in covid
and we know that now but that work is
happening on a ground level so though
the uptake is small maybe four or five
in each session it's still powerful it's
still hitting the most vulnerable
uh the number of CQ number of people
seeking food from support from food
banks has gone up
um it's been an upward trend for the
last three years it's again no great
surprise what is difficult is that our
food banks are struggling more they're
having to make new Partnerships they're
having to increase their ability to get
food in but
our feedback is fantastic the one that
we get the numbers from so we don't get
some Mark's numbers at the moment but
we're hoping to add those into the next
dashboard but what they do is they work
it get across the two districts Castle
point and Rochford so that the fresh
food that comes in is used at the right
time so for instance across two
districts are supported that line isn't
there for residents and food bank is set
up at the mega Center at the Hub
um so the number of those seeking
supporting crisis
um that it feels a little bit and live
with us that is a Citizens advice figure
and that is the people that really phone
up and you know they are in tears you
know they've got multiple problems but
what you tend to find is it's they're in
crisis and there's always a financial
element to that
um
number seeking support for other crisis
interventions so that's usually quite
specific but again we've asked them to
drill down on that and it's it's usually
the secondary issue so they might be
phoning enough about a divorce or a
separation but debt management and money
always comes into that so we find time
and time again that intervention is
really really needed
um debt is rising we was given a warning
probably around about a year ago as we
was coming out of the covid phase by
citizens advice as we know that people
couldn't could get evicted that people
were going to be claiming debts back and
going to court that there would be an
upris and that is the case I've been
working on a report that I'd love to
kind of present in the future
um environment or present it through
cancer Williams just looking at the
quarter three citizens advice outcomes
for uh 2022 versus 2021 and I can tell
you there's almost a 25 uplift across
most of that activity which is huge but
this this endeavor in the detail it's
really really interesting
um energy debt which everyone thought
was going to be the big one everyone's
is
um it's not as big as I thought it was
because people were prepared
um those that were the most vulnerable
on key meters had already topped up they
were clever they knew that they if they
topped up for October they'd be on the
old rate so there is a need
but it's not as strong as we thought it
was going to be because people knew
their debts their bills were going up
people were prepared but we are still
giving out household grants so the
household Grant is given out by citizens
of ice in this District it's not
advertised and the reason it's not
advertised is that once people
understand that it's there they'll go
back it is for the most vulnerable and
the most in need it is an opportunity
for people to get some prepayment
vouchers for their energy meters for the
gas and their electrics and food
vouchers but it's a service they don't
just get the vouchers they do need to
have a little conversation about their
debt management their money management
and their budgeting and so those figures
will come probably on a quarterly basis
um number seeking support with rent
council tax risk eviction again on just
finalizing those that data from citizens
advice but they have literally sent me
through this afternoon Feb and January's
data as well so once you get to the next
dashboard what you'll see is where the
green lines are you'll see a light green
line so you'll have December January's
February's March April's May so you'll
be able to start them comparing where we
are on any given issue at any given
month in terms of comms I had to change
this slightly so you saw a slightly
different version of this last time and
it had three which was total posts
clicks through to the cost of living
website and the third one was total
reach but as soon as I pay into the
table the new numbers went skew where
um because the reach is 12 686 which is
huge that means that people are seeing
our social media posts they are seeing
the toolkit that was created by the the
working group and they are getting the
information that they need
um
and that also comes down to you as well
as counselors as those that are sharing
that information those are active on
social media those that are advising
their residents that there is support
available so I think it's a collective
kind of well done for everyone
particularly our comms team because you
know Anna's really on it she's been
fantastic she's really
um
quick to to change when we need to
um so the last box on this slide on the
dashboard is identified needs and trends
and in here what we'll what I'll try and
do is just pull out some of that
information into some sentences because
when you look at it flat on a page it
doesn't mean much so you know one of the
examples is the food banks have seen an
increase in 13 just in December so we
know that usually happens a little bit
but that's a massive increase
um warm hubs in the district on average
three to four per session
um
the
uh the last one what should we set up to
offer 1 480 spaces across an average of
three days that is for
um out of school holiday activities so
that's Essex data
um we have just received the data for
the December holidays but we've also
already got another holiday coming up I
understand it was well taken up so that
will be some some increased information
that will appear in that box
um periodically but not monthly and the
last item that I wanted to add um just
raised today was a hold the day so
councilor Williams is the chair of
health and well be involved the health
and will be involved is Castle point in
Rochford but they've taken cost of
living seriously you know it's it's 50
plus Partners so our cost of living
working group is 10 partners
the health and well-being involved is 50
plus Partners it's got a really strong
strategy and cost of living sits
seamlessly within our health and
well-being strategy
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to bring the board meeting
together we're going to have an open
market event and we're going to invite
residents I've got a little bit of kovic
money left please don't tell us it's
County Council but I'm going to spend
that to buy slow cookers
food vouchers to give away for Tescos
and local supermarkets we are going to
cook some low-cost meals we'll be giving
away meals on the day recipe cards and
everything to do we're also going to be
fingers crossed I'm hoping it'll be
finalized this week doing 10-minute
budget sessions upstairs so there'll be
some proactive stuff we will we're happy
to pay travel so I will facilitate for
Mega Center to pay back any bus fares
that are presented to them coming with
your bus ticket you present it you can
get that paid back so families have been
able to come we've also got children's
play because if parents want to talk
there's a play area so I wanted to raise
that so although it's not just because
of cost of living Road Show it's the
whole gamble it is health and well-being
for our residents and it just shows how
kind of active and interested partners
are and I'd like to end really and just
say to you this dashboard it's a work in
progress it doesn't look like much right
now but actually once you get to
September and September is a really key
day for the cost of living working group
because we need to plan for next year we
need to not be in the same position
where we're trying to get hubs up and
running in December two weeks before
Christmas where we know that sits in
survivors capacity in terms of
volunteers to support people we know
that revs has the opportunity to get out
there and really support the
organizations and the projects that help
our residents so although it's
informative and it'll be informative for
you for the next three four months
when it comes key and I think when it
becomes a consideration is when we come
back in September October with a plan
that will see us through
um you know winter 23 24. that's it for
me if you've got any questions I'm happy
to take them
thank you Kelly
councilor Williams yeah thank you
chairman um as you can hear we we
haven't done very much
um
it's phenomenal what uh Tracy uh Kelly
and their team have done and I'd just
like to say thank you very much I'm also
involved with it with Ralston and the
mega Center and it's a joy and absolute
joy to see the look on people's faces
thank you I really mean that really
thank you
thank you councilor Williams
um don't know who put Council award
thank you very much that's nice to be
deferred by a very courteous lady
um just one thing I'm really struggling
to see what's on that dashboard and I
would have appreciated it if maybe it
had been sent beforehand so I could have
maybe looked at it on the screen because
I'm really I'm struggling you know to
see that but that's
that's it thank you
I sent a very polite notice there around
the first of the month and I asked for
the data to try and Wing its way to me
by the 14th so that I can present it in
finding report on the 21st but I've said
to Tracy rather than Tracy coming back
and doing this what we'll do is on the
21st I'm happy to give it to Tracy and
for it to be sent to the executive and
if you've got any questions you can just
come straight back to us then rather
than it being so formal for you all the
time and we always feel like we're
catching up because we haven't quite got
the data I'd rather send you the data
when it's full than when I'm half empty
thank you thank you I just want thanks
to that as well
um
these meeting the last meeting we had on
the Wednesday I couldn't make it
unfortunately but I was then asked to
submit my report for this month on the
Friday
and there's little to add to that so
there might be some mileage in extending
whether it's every month or bi-monthly
to make it a bit more meaningful because
you know my passion and I'm very upfront
my passion is delivery to the community
and as much as I want to keep members
informed actually I want to make it a
meaningful
engagement process rather than me just
turning up to go yay we're doing a great
job but um yeah so that was kind of my
ask if we could just maybe extend it
slightly
okay any other points
councilor Belton
um thank you first off well
um we know there's an awful lot going on
and we hear about it from Council
Williams and other meetings but to see
it in this format and to hear the detail
is just incredible
um so well done to everybody involved in
making that happen and obviously as
members if there is anything we can do
to support that obviously sharing on
social media but anything else please
let us know because we all want to help
and lastly the Roadshow which sounds
incredible did you say you've got a date
for that set is there a save the date I
have a date so the save the date is the
29th of March it's at the mega Center
it'll be an afternoon event two till six
you're all invited a safety date will go
out with members bulletin either this
week or next week once I've got some of
the items confirmed because I don't want
to tell you that we're doing it without
telling you a few things that happening
and making sure it's there but I'd
really love you all to come and because
I'd like you to talk to our partners and
realistically you you will hear some of
the most fantastic stories not from me
I'm a big fan of making them celebrate
we've done this before the last Road
show was particularly successful and
partners being able to actually just
listen to each other sometimes it's
really helpful for them so it's 29th of
March would absolutely loved for you to
come what we've got at the end is part
of the health and well-being board we
have put together a collection of videos
so we have we have a small budget and we
have four areas four priority areas
within the health and well-being
strategy and we've put through together
it's being filmed at the moment and
there's 16 plus Partners across Castle
point in Rochford short shot videos and
we'll be doing a video launch on the
night with a small glass of Prosecco
which will be the kind of the later part
of the session so that it's it's a road
shape also a time for you to come and
join us and celebrate with our partners
and we'd really appreciate that and
you'll get a flavor of what they do
individually
thank you
any other points councilor Rowe
thank you chairman
um I totally hear what Tracy says and I
would like to propose that we do have my
monthly updates I think that would be
very useful for this executive so I
propose that we have bi-monthly
updates Tracy please thank you if I can
have a second
Williams he's seconding it and we all
agree to that recommendation
agreed right hey councilor Mrs Belton
just just one point um completely happy
with bi-monthly and understand what
everybody said if anything prudent
happens between those times I would just
ask that we're updated in case there's
something pressing that you need our
support on or something that we a
message that we need to get out
thank you
and I want to just sum up and make a few
points in relation to to the report
first of all Kelly
um thank you very much indeed for your
time this evening
um that wasn't a presentation by slides
that was passion
um and what I like to hear is when
aside or a couple of slides are
supported with the passion and and the
conviction with which you delivered your
presentation uh you've got a bit of
audience participation there there was a
good Round of Applause and I totally
support that round of applause thank you
um I'm always very proud when Rochford
is shown in lights on the national stage
and thank you under your leadership
Tracy as director for this piece of
activity for the work that you're doing
to raise the profile nationally
um I always pause when I say teams
because I know that behind teams there's
not actually very many people that's the
way it is
um a couple of you but uh well what
passion and under
um Council Williams portfolio holder
he's keeping an Eagle Eye and attends
meetings and I know he is also very
passionate from a member point of view
so when last May I think it was it was
quite apparent that we'd got a cost of
living crisis and brought about for a
number of reasons and I won't go to
those reasons but obviously the
spotlight was very much on Heating and
we know and I thought you made a really
good point the fact that people did
prepare for that to a certain extent
assisted with price caps and help for
various people some broad help for
people pensioners but also some
specifically targeted help to those in
need
but when I first raised the subject and
said I wanted Rockford to lead the way I
recognized that we would could only ever
really be a signposting service working
with agencies
we could do certain things in terms of
council tax support and various bits but
it was really a tip of the iceberg and
that is still very much the case we
don't have a Fortune of money to be able
to hand out it's not our role it's not
the expectation that we can but if we
can actually bring people together
signpost them help them do our very best
and really Point them to agencies that
are far more qualified enable than we
are then I think we're doing our job but
then of course when I said a month or
two ago actually can this report be
enhanced to bring data I also recognize
what a difficult task that was because
providing data Gathering data from
people a lot of people that are quite
shall I say
disappointed or ashamed of themselves
through no thought of their own that
they're having to resort to food banks
or they're having to resort to
assistance so it is always going to be
difficult to capture that data and a lot
of people will go under the radar but
nevertheless I don't think that's a
reason not to actually do our best to
try and capture the data and say what
we're doing in our in our little bit so
all I really want to do is say Well done
thank you for that report I think rather
than ticking the box and just coming
back each month and looking at the cost
of living report it makes it much more
meaningful when you're able to report
some good data but really I'm very very
proud when Roxford is on the map it's
exactly what I want to do in Roxford and
show that
we lead where others follow and we're
doing that in one or two areas of our
business which I'm extremely proud of
but it's really the people that make it
happen thank you for your passion thank
you very much indeed and we go really to
the one recommendation which is at page
7.1 on the report at item one 1.1 that
the update on the cost of living
response and work of the cost of living
working group be noted is that noted
members
and I should have mentioned of course
the the working group contributing
hugely to this and I meant to mention
them so thank them for their support
because this is a subject this is what
it's about it's working in our community
so thank you very much for that and I
think that actually concludes our agenda
for this evening and I will close the
meeting at 8 17 p.m thank you very much
indeed members thank you very much
indeed officers thank you very much
indeed for visiting councilors thank you